[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen den Sport hat Norbert Lehmann
für Sie einen schönen guten Abend von
mir schauen wir auf unsere großen Themen
Rutsch in Niger Aufständische Offiziere
setzen den ersten demokratisch gewählten
Präsidenten ab die Folge gewaltsame
Unruhen in der Hauptstadt
[Musik]
an der Nordsee brennt weiter jetzt wird
wieder über die Feuergefahr durch
e-autobatterien diskutiert
und das große verdrängen wegen der
aktuellen Krisen suchen einer Studie
zufolge immer mehr Menschen ihr Glück im
privat
[Musik]
im westafrikanischen Liga hat das
Militär die Macht ergriffen
UN-Generalsekretär gut herrisch und auch
die Bundesregierung forderten von den
pochisten die Freilassung des
inhaftierten Präsidenten war so
Niger liegt im Zentrum Westafrikas und
gilt als Letzter Staat in der Region in
dem westliche Länder noch Einfluss haben
einige der angrenzenden Staaten etwa
Libyen Mali oder Burkina
am Flughafen der nigerischen Hauptstadt
nyamei unterhält die Bundeswehr einen
wichtigen Stützpunkt über den Sie den
gesamten Truppenabzug aus Mali abwickelt
Sandra Theis berichtet
vor und im Gebäude der Regierungspartei
niam may brennt es Demonstranten die den
Putsch unterstützen haben unter anderem
Fahrzeuge angezündet und plündern
gestern hatte eine Gruppe von Militärs
den Präsidenten festgesetzt und die
Machtübernahme erklärt die Institution
der Republik sind ausgesetzt die
Generalsekretäre der Ministerien
übernehmen das Tagesgeschäft die
verteidigungs- und Sicherheitskräfte
managen die Situation
am Morgen erklärte der abgesetzte
Präsident Mohammed bazoom in einem Tweet
an den hart erkämpften Errungenschaften
wird festgehalten dafür werden alle nie
Gras sorgen die Freiheit und Demokratie
lieben
doch jene die für den Präsidenten auf
die Straße gingen wurden mit
Waffengewalt vertrieben Landesgrenzen
und Luftraum geschlossen der Putsch
betrifft auch den Abzug der rund 1000
deutschen Soldaten aus dem benachbarten
Mali der sollte über den
lufttransportstützpunkt den niam
mailaufen dort sitzen jetzt rund 100
Bundeswehrsoldaten fest von hier wollte
der Westen den Kampf gegen den
Terrorismus in der Region führen bei
einem Besuch im April erklärte
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius dieser
Punkt
der Lufttransport Stützpunkt ist
Drehscheibe für alle Aktivitäten von uns
und von anderen europäischen Nationen
hier in Afrika und deswegen
unverzichtbar hunderte bejubelten heute
den Putsch schwenkten dabei teilweise
russische Fahnen beobachter befürchten
dass das Land sich jetzt Russland
annähert
der Putsch könnte auch Russland die Tür
öffnen sich auch mega auszubreiten und
Russland will keine Stabilität in Afrika
aus dann will
Waffen verkaufen und möglichst viel
Probleme den besten machen wer die
pochisten sind ist unklar sicher ist nur
eines ihre Machtübernahme könnte die
ganze Sahel Region weiter die
stabilisieren
was bedeutet denn der putzschirmleger
für die Strategie der Bundesregierung in
der Region also noch hält sich die
Bundesregierung mit einer Bewertung
zurück weil sie die Situation noch
beobachtet aber es könnte ein herber im
Rückschlag werden für die Strategie im
doppelter Hinsicht zum einen hat
Deutschland zusammen mit der EU versucht
in der sahelregion Sicherheit Stabilität
und Eigenverantwortung zu stärken auch
um eine der größten Migrationsrouten in
Richtung Europa zu beeinflussen und
jetzt sieht es so aus als ob von den
fünf Staaten mit denen man sich dort mal
zusammengetan hat zu diesem Zweck nur
noch zwei übrig sein und das wäre dann
äh damit stünde das ganze Projekt doch
deutlich auf der Kippe und zum anderen
gibt es wieder Zweifel an den Methoden
mit denen man diese Strategie verfolgt
denn auch Deutschland hat sich dort an
der Ausbildung von Sicherheitskräften
beteiligt da hat es früh Zweifel dran
gegeben und kritische Stimmen die gesagt
haben wie stellt man sicher dass diese
Sicherheitskräfte sich nicht zu
irgendeinem Zeitpunkt gegen die eigene
Regierung wenden und auch heute werden
solche kritischen Stimmen wieder laut
die sagen ist man eigentlich sicher dass
von deutsche ausgebildete
Sicherheitskräfte nicht teil gehabt
haben an diesem Putsch das wird die
Bundesregierung sicherlich auch noch mal
aufmerksam beobachten und prüfen also
keine gute Entwicklung und die
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock hat
sich jetzt auch sofort gemeldet hat die
Freilassung des nigerischen Präsidenten
gefordert und die Rückkehr zur
verfassungsmäßigen Ordnung danke schön
russland versucht sich in Afrika mehr
Einfluss zu sichern viele Länder dort
sind besonders auf Getreidelieferungen
angewiesen diese sind jedoch gefährdet
seit Russland das getreideabkommen mit
der Ukraine nicht mehr weiterführen will
nun hat cramme Chef Putin zum zweiten
russischen afrika-gipfel in St
Petersburg geladen dort fordert sie
Afrikanische Union Friedensverhandlungen
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine wer
von Luc Weipert
roter Teppich für Afrika Präsident Putin
als gipfelgastgeber auch wenn nur 17
Staatschefs meist enge Verbündete
moskauz dabei sind ansonsten nur
Minister oder Botschafter putin wird für
mehr wirtschaftliche und militärische
Zusammenarbeit mit Afrika der Putsche
Niger offiziell kein Tagesordnungspunkt
diskutiert wird darüber umso mehr auch
über Putins macht Politik beim
aufkündigen des getreideabkommens mit
der Ukraine der Vorsitzende der
Afrikanischen Union wurde deutlich die
Ukraine Krise müsste dringend friedlich
gelöst werden die Lebensmittelversorgung
Afrikas hänge davon ab
Russland ist ein strategischer Partner
30% der afrikanischen weizenimporte
kommen aus Russland aber wir brauchen
Getreide aus Russland und der Ukraine
deshalb muss dringend ein Abkommen her
Putin beteuerte erneut der Westen sei
Schuld angesichts der anhaltenden Kritik
der afrikanischen Gäste bot der
russische Präsident aber verlässliche
Getreidelieferungen an
Russland kann ukrainisches Getreide
durch russisches ersetzen wir werden
besonders Bedürftigen Ländern wie Mali
Burkina Faso Eritrea oder Somalia 25 bis
30.000 Tonnen kostenlos bereitstellen
eine Wiederaufnahme des
getreideabkommens mit der Ukraine lehnte
Putin aber kategorisch ab zugleich
versprach er sich dafür einzusetzen dass
die Afrikanische Union in die g20-gruppe
der größten Industrienationen
aufgenommen wird
durch das Auslaufen des
getreideabkommens ist es für die Ukraine
noch schwieriger geworden Getreide zu
exportieren auch heute sollen nach
ukrainischen Angaben wieder Hafenanlagen
in der Region Odessa von russischen
Streitkräften beschossen worden sein
über die schwierige Lage der
ukrainischen Bauern berichtet da Hassan
3000 Hektar Land beackert Bauer Bailey
letzten Sommer hoffte er dass das
getreideabkommen kommen mag dieses Jahr
fürchtete er dessen Ende Beli verkaufte
deshalb seine Ernte direkt vom Feld noch
bevor das Abkommen auslief
wir versuchten alles so schnell wie
möglich zu verkaufen der Preis war nicht
gut für uns aber wir mussten ihn in
dieser Situation akzeptieren was zählt
wir verkauften es dieses Jahr
nur das Saatgut für nächstes Jahr steht
noch im Lager die Halle ist leer
verkauft auch deshalb dürfen wir hier
Filmen volle Silos willkommen mein
Landwirt in nur deshalb zeigen aus Angst
vor russischen Luftangriffen die
russische Armee beschießt gezielt
Getreide Lager über 60.000 Tonnen
Getreide sind verbrannt nach
ukrainischen Angaben
Russlands Interesse ist die vollständige
Zerstörung der Ukraine als Rivale im
Getreidehandel
wir wissen dass es ihre Priorität ist
nur das eigene Getreide auf den Markt zu
bringen
so werden auch agrarbe Triebe in diesem
russischen Angriffskrieg zu
strategischen Zielen
wenn wir es nicht bekommen soll es
niemand bekommen es ist ein bekanntes
Sprichwort leider trifft es zu
es ist ein Zitat aus einem alten
sowjet-film Bauer Billy findet das
beschreibe ganz treffend die russische
Vorgehensweise im getreideabkommen
für eine Verlängerung der preisbremsen
für Strom und Gas bis Ostern 2024 hat
sich Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
ausgesprochen es gebe bereits Gespräche
mit der EU darüber
habeg spricht von einer
Vorsichtsmaßnahme für den Winter stand
jetzt würden die Energiepreis Bremsen
zum Jahresende auslaufen sie Deckeln den
Preis für Strom bei 40 Cent je
Kilowattstunde für Gas bei 12 Cent
aktuell sind die versorgertarife für
Neukundinnen und Kunden deutlich
günstiger
keine guten Nachrichten für die Pflege
in Deutschland immer weniger Menschen
beginnen eine Ausbildung zur
Pflegefachkraft laut Statistischen
Bundesamt haben 2022 und 52.000 Menschen
eine sprechende Ausbildung begonnen 7%
weniger als im Vorjahr der Bundesverband
privater Pflegeanbieter nannte die
Zahlen ein Drama
die Sorge ist groß dass es zu einer
Umweltkatastrophe in der Nordsee kommt
der noch immer brennt ein Frachter der
mit fast 3.800 Autos beladen ist sinkt
da oder Berichte auseinander könnte eine
ölpestrohen das Feuer brachen dann
nachts nördlich der Wattenmeerinsel
Ameland aus obwohl der Frachter mit
einem Bergungsschiff vertäubt war
driftete er nach Westen ab und liegt nun
etwa 16 km nördlich der Insel
Terschelling gun
zwei Stunden neue Bilder die Free mental
Highway brennt noch immer vom Frachter
zieht Rauch über eine der Fahrerinnen
die Küstenwache hält Abstand gestern
redet sie per Funk über die Brandursache
das Gespräch wird abgehört
es fing an in der Batterie eines
Elektroautos 25 davon sind ein Bord eins
ist wohl explodiert
der Akku eines E-Autos kann durch einen
Fabrikationsfehler oder bei einem Unfall
in Brand geraten er besteht aus vielen
Modulen in denen sich einzelne
Batteriezellen befinden
wenn eine davon einen Defekt hat kann
sie sich stark erwärmen es entstehen
entzündliche Gase so kann in einer
Kettenreaktion ein Brand entstehen der
von außen mit Löschwasser schlecht zu
erreichen ist deshalb muss der Akku in
einem Wasserbad lange gekühlt werden
Lars Tober Schuld Schiffsbesatzungen in
Brandbekämpfung immer mehr Elektroautos
als Fracht das Verlangen neue
Löschtechnik auf den Schiffen da muss
man sich noch mal einen Kopf machen wie
ich auch Kühlung in das Schiff bekomme
weil zurzeit wird mit CO2 oder
ultraleicht-schrauben gelöscht und dass
der Kühleffekt also zu vernachlässigen
und da muss dran gearbeitet werden bei
allen Autos steige die Brandlast die
Free mental Highway hier Archivbilder
hat er zudem fast 1000 Autos mehr
geladen als ursprünglich gemeldet im
letzten Jahr brannte bereits im Atlantik
ein anderer Auto Frachter auch damals
galt ein E-Auto als mögliche Ursache
benötigt und jetzt auch noch dieses
Schiff das zeigt es gibt Vorschriften
für den Transport von Elektroautos aber
die reichen offenbar nicht aus
der Brand so sagen selbst die Räder
müssen ein Weckruf sein
und auf Ameland ist für uns Isabel
Schäfers Isabel wie läuft aktuell der
Einsatz
also der Frachter brennt noch immer und
ist auch weiterhin viel zu heiß als dass
jemand an Bord gehen könnte man musste
mittlerweile sogar aufhören von außen
Wasser an das Schiff zu bringen um es
runter zu kühlen weil dadurch zu viel
Wasser an Bord kamen und das Schiff zu
kentern drohte und das ist weiterhin das
oberste Ziel das Sinken der Schiffes zu
verhindern deshalb konzentrieren sich
die Rettungskräfte hier jetzt auch vor
allem darauf das Schiff stabil zu halten
mit Hilfe eines schlepperschiffes und
das gelingt wohl derzeit auch ganz gut
die Lage sei stabil haben wir hier
gehört zwar bewegt sich das Schiff
durchaus erst heute etwas nach Westen
und dann nach Osten ähm jetzt wieder
zurück aber wohl alles relativ
kontrolliert und auch so dass die
Fahrerinnen alle frei sind und der
Schiff Verkehr hier eigentlich relativ
problemlos weiterlaufen kann was
weiterhin unklar ist ist ob man den
Brand so weit unter Kontrolle kriegt
dass der Frachter am Ende abgeschleppt
werden kann oder ob nicht doch letztlich
nur die Option noch möglich ist dass man
den Frachter dann hoffentlich relativ
kontrolliert komplett ausbrennen lassen
muss danke schön Isabel Schäfers
die Europäische Zentralbank hat es
wieder getan den Leitzins angehoben so
wie sie die hohe Inflation drücken laut
der Zins noch im Juli vergangenen Jahres
bei null Prozent klettert er nun auf
4,25%. bislang ging die Rechnung der EZB
einigermaßen auf die Inflation im
Euroraum ist von 10,6% in der Spitze auf
zuletzt 5,5% gesunken für alle die ein
Kredit brauchen kann der angehobene
Leitzins ein Problem sein für alle die
sparen kann er hingegen gut sein aber es
gilt aufzupassen Isabel
wenn Geschäftsbanken ihr Geld hier bei
der EZB parken bekommen sie dafür
endlich mehr Zinsen diesen Vorteil aber
geben nicht alle Kreditinstitute an ihre
Kunden weiter jede fünfte Bank zahlt
nach einer Umfrage fürs Tagesgeld
weiterhin 0 Zinsen
haben die Kontoführungsgebühren und
alles mögliche nur aber rausgeben sie
nix also schon sind jetzt wieder oben ne
und da könnten mal ein paar Zinsen geben
die Angebote bundesweit tätiger Banken
liegen im Schnitt bei 1,3% während
Regionalbanken beim Tagesgeld nur 0,36%
im Schnitt zahlen die Volksbanken und
Sparkassen haben in den Regionen weniger
Konkurrenz und Vertrauen offenbar auf
die Treue ihrer Kunden
regionalen Bereich da schaut die
Sparkasse vielleicht noch welche
Konditionen die örtliche Volksbank
anbietet und sie zu dass sich die
Konditionen nicht allzu sehr
unterscheiden aber bei den bundesweit
aktiven Banken da ist der Wettbewerb
natürlich ungleich höher und davon
profitieren die Sparer in Form von
höheren Zinsen 0 Zinsen beim Tagesgeld
die Sparkassen sagen es gebe schließlich
noch andere Finanzprodukte des Tagesgeld
ist ein Produkt aus einer ganzen Palette
von Produkten und das führt ein bisschen
in die Irre wenn man nur auf das
Tagesgeld schaut wie das Kaninchen auf
die Schlange eine Ausrede meinen
Verbraucherschützer sie wollen
vielleicht lieber ihre Zertifikate Fonds
und Versicherung verkaufen weil da mehr
Geld verdient wird aber für den
verbraucherbedarf ist ein Tagesgeldkonto
einfach das Mittel der Wahl wenn das
Geld nicht langfristig angelegt werden
soll und absolut sicher angelegt werden
soll sollte die EZB einen weiteren
Zinsschritt gehen werden sich auch die
Regionalbanken dem steigenden
wettbewerbs-
Licht und Schatten bei der Deutschen
Bahn im ersten Halbjahr 2023
transportierte sie im Fernverkehr 15%
mehr Fahrgäste zugleich fuhr sie ein
Verlust von 71 Millionen Euro ein wegen
gestiegener Kosten und Investitionen ins
Schienennetz
hauptverlustbringer ist der Güterverkehr
viele Baustellen führten zu noch mehr
Verspätungen nur knapp 69% der Fernzüge
waren pünktlich
in Griechenland kämpfen die Feuerwehren
noch immer gegen zahlreiche Waldbrände
ihr größter Gegner ist der Wind auf der
Urlaubsinsel Rhodos brechen deshalb
immer wieder neue Feuer aus zurzeit
haben die Einsatzkräfte die Lager aber
unter Kontrolle wie es heißt in Athen
gedachte Militärangehörige der beiden
getöteten Piloten eines löschflugzeuges
deren Maschine vorgestern bei einem
Einsatz abgestürzt war
vor 70 Jahren endete der Koreakrieg ein
Datum dass das nordkoreanische Regime
zum Anlass nimmt Stärke zu demonstrieren
und zwar vom Schulterschluss mit
Russland
Verteidigungsminister Scholl GU besuchte
mit Nordkoreas Machthaber Kim Jong Un
eine Waffenschau beide betonten ihre
militärische Zusammenarbeit
nordkorea hatte von Anfang an den
russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
unterstützt den Vorwurf der USA Waffen
an Russland zu liefern jedoch zurück
die große Mehrheit der Menschen in
Deutschland fühlt sich von den aktuellen
Krisen überfordert und reagiert darauf
mit einer Flucht ins private Glück so
das Ergebnis einer repräsentativen
Studie des Kölner rheingold-instituts
unter 1000 Menschen im Alter zwischen 18
und 65 Jahren dort die Färber berichtet
Waldbrände Dürre Krieg Inflation die
Lage in der Welt scheint vielen Menschen
in diesen Zeiten überfordert damit
umzugehen eine Herausforderung
ich weiß es nicht also ich sehe der
Zukunft so ein bisschen
mit gemischten Gefühlen entgegen alles
Politik Krieg es wird alles teurer
Gehälter werden immer niedriger
als sehr sehr herabgehend was mein
persönliches soziales Umfeld angeht da
bin ich sehr zuversichtlich weil da bin
ich ja der Mitgestalter wie
zuversichtlich sind die Deutschen das
Kölner Rheingold Institut hat dazu eine
repräsentative Studie erstellt das
Ergebnis im privaten Bereich sind die
Menschen sehr optimistisch
87%. die Zuversicht in die Politik
hingegen ist gering 77% sind da
pessimistisch
also es ist so als wenn sich zwischen
eine eigenen Welt und der Welt da
draußen ein verdrängungsvorhang
geschoben hätte man will nicht mehr das
beunruhigen die das krisenhafte
wahrnehmen man kapuziert sich auf sich
und seine wohlfühl oder Hasen Rückzug
ins privater also Haus und Garten die
Familie die bedrohlich empfundene Welt
bleibt draußen mit
folgendemokratie kann nur funktionieren
wenn die Menschen sich mit der
Wirklichkeit auseinandersetzen diese
rückzuchtendenzen diese Hermetik im
sozialen führt auf lange Sicht dazu dass
die Demokratie Schaden nimmt die
Menschen konzentrieren sich aufs
persönliche eine Herausforderung für die
Politik
und wir schauen auch heute natürlich
wieder auf die Fußball-WM was machen
denn die deutschen Spielerinnen sich
natürlich auf das womöglich
entscheidende Gruppenspiel am Sonntag
gegen Kolumbien vor ja und alle wissen
das wird ein anderer Kick als beim
Souveränität gegen Marokko heute
intensives Training im deutschen
Quartier vor den Toren ist
Flügelstürmer wenn Jule Brandt läuft
heute kurzfristig abseits der
Seitenlinie leichte Rückenprobleme
verhindern ihren Einsatz im
Mannschaftstraining vor dem Kräftemessen
gegen Kolumbien wissen dass es ein sehr
körperbetonter Gegner sein wird dass wir
auch eventuell den Ball dann mal ein
bisschen früher spielen müssen das
turnierdebüt der bislang verletzten Lena
Oberdorf könnte eine willkommene
Verstärkung sein es zeichnet sie diese
Zweikampfstärke aus und deswegen liebe
ich es immer er sie in meinem Team zu
haben anstatt jetzt bei den Gegnern erst
in drei Tagen muss die Bundestrainerin
ihren Personalplan offenlegen
heute in der Gruppe E die Wiederauflage
des WM Finals von 2019 USA gegen die
Niederlande Oranier ging schon in der 17
minute durch Jill Rock in Führung erst
in der zweiten Halbzeit die
us-weltmeisterin am Drücker das 1:1
durch Lindsey Orange in der 62 Minute
ein leistungsgerechtes Unentschieden
beide Teams mit guten Chancen aus
Achtelfinale
die weiteren Ergebnisse des Tages
Portugal schlägt Vietnam 2:0 und Co
Gastgeber Australien verliert knapp
gegen starke Nigerianerinnen mit zwei zu
drei
zur Tode France der Frauen einer
erfolgreicher Tag für die deutschen
radrennfahrerinnen
Ricarda Bauernfeind gewinnt die fünfte
Etappe nach 126 Kilometern von Uni
löcherau nach Albi der Tagessieg der
bislang größte Erfolg ihrer Karriere und
hinter der Schweizerin marien Reusser
fährt Lian Lippert als dritte ins Ziel
sie hatte ja auch schon eine Tourette
gewonnen
ja und sie ist die große Überraschung
beim WTA Turnier in hamburg-rotenbaum
Nummer
akkue das 19 Jahre alte Tennis Talent
aus Reinbek gewinnt nach zwei Stunden
und 42 Minuten das hat umkämpfte Match
gegen die Favoritin aus Italien Martina
mit fünf zu sieben sechs vier sieben
fünf ja und steht im Halbfinale die 27
der weltklangliste überzeugte durch
Kampfgeist Nervenstärke und Angriffslust
ja ich bin mir sicher von der Wärme noch
einiges sehen und hören sehr schön
morgen wird es wieder etwas wärmer für
die meisten die Sonne zeigt sich
durchaus auch mal wo genau das erfahren
Sie gleich von Katja Hornbach das heute
journal können Sie um 21:45 Uhr mit
Dunja Hayali sehen und hier begrüßt sie
morgen mit risin bis bald
[Musik]
guten Abend das ist eine wirklich
eindrucksvolle wolkenspirale dieses
Tiefs Ventur das uns hier in Deutschland
heute doch sehr viel Regen gebracht hat
gerne würden wir den Regen einfach ans
Mittelmeer schicken wo ja immer noch die
Waldbrände toben dafür regnet es bei uns
heute Nacht noch kräftig weiter zum Teil
sind auch Gewitter dabei am ehesten
trocken ist es zwischen dem Allgäu und
dem Oberrhein der Wind kommt aus
südwestlichen Richtung die Temperaturen
sind recht mild in dieser Nacht sie
sinken auf 17 bis 13 Grad nur am
Alpenrand wird es mit 11 Grad kühler und
morgen ist es dann für die meisten von
uns doch etwas wärmer als heute und sie
erwarten 21 Grad in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen an den Küsten von Nord
und Ostsee und bis zu 27 Grad in der
Lausitz oder auch in Ostbayern und
erstmal regnet es noch dann aber locker
die Wolken mehr und mehr auf und es
entwickeln sich Regenschauer und
Gewitter und am ehesten trocken ist es
an der Küste und auch am Alpen hat heute
hat es ja schon recht kräftig geregnet
innerhalb von 24 Stunden bis zu 35 Liter
pro Quadratmeter morgen wird das viel
weniger sein da sind das nur so fünf bis
15 Liter pro Quadratmeter und sehr
wechselhaft geht es dann auch in den
nächsten Tagen weiter bei ähnlichen
Temperaturen guten Abend